هذه هي المرأة التي تقف وراء
الأغنية الأكثر شهرة
والتلفزيون ، لكن هل تعلم أن هذه
المرأة مسؤولة أيضًا عن
بعض الأغاني الأكثر شهرة على الراديو في
القرن الماضي ، سيكون
شهر سبتمبر ، حسنًا ، ماذا فعلت
تستحق هذه ،
يا لها من أغنية جيدة ، حركها من
طاولة بيفرلي هيلز ،
فأنت أيضًا الأفضل في لعبة الكاراتيه بهذه
الطريقة ، لفة الموسيقى ذات اللون الأرجواني ، وهي عبارة عن
الكثير من الأغاني التي كتبتها أكثر من
ألف أغنية جيسوس
أنا حليف  ويليس
أنا من مشاهير كتاب الأغاني جرامي
إيمي توني والحائز على جائزة وكاتب الأغاني الحائز على جائزة ويبي
والمدير
الفني ومدير
الحفلات والفنانين الاجتماعيين أهم واحد لا
أعرف كيف أفعل أي شيء لا أعرف
كيف أخطط له هو  اجعل الموسيقى تقرأ أو أكتب الموسيقى التي شاهدتها
[موسيقى]
أقل من خمس مسرحيات موسيقية قبل
أن ألقي اللون الأرجواني ، فأنا أفضل عندما
لا أعرف ما أفعله في هذه الحالة
لا بد أنها لم تكن تعرف حقًا ما
كانت تفعله عندما  كتبت سأكون هناك
بالنسبة لك ، أغنية الرسوم لأصدقائها ،
حصلت على ترشيح لجائزة إيمي
وخسرنا في موضوع Star Trek Voyager
، وأجرؤ على أي شخص أن يغني الآن
مقارنةً بموضوع الأصدقاء ،
لكن هكذا تسير الأمور
مع ذلك ، كلهم موجودون هناك  لأنك
دخلت في تاريخ ثقافة البوب تمامًا مثل نج
ح علي الكبير في سبتمبر مثل Earth
Wind and Fire ، هل تتذكر أن ال
يلة 21 هي سبتمبر كان الحب يغ
ر عقول المتخيلين أثناء مط
ردة السحب بعيدًا ، أر
نا عن قصد كتابة أغنية سع
دة و  لا أعتقد أن هناك أي
أغنية أسعد من شهر سبتمبر في بداية
عام 1978 ، كنت في فود ستامبس
مساعدين طبيين أقرب ما
يكون إلى الرفاهية دون أن أكون في
الواقع بحلول نهاية العام ، كنت قد بعت 10
ملايين سجل كان  تجربة سريالية
كانت حياتي كلها
إذا لم يُسمح لي بأن أكون عاجًا
مبدعًا يتلاشى ويموت ، أعتقد أن افتح
التابوت عندما ترميني هناك
عندما أتوقف على الرغم من أنني سأظل كذلك
مثل الضرب إلى جانب سماع
نوع من الإيقاع
[موسيقى]